mais vous savez ça veut dire ce qu il y
ait un beau monde avec une vidéo qui
s'appelait ou pas c'est une meilleure
journée que ester sur un seul président
qui s'appelait watch paypal bord watch
pipoles die inside un truc très très
connu là c'est un peu différent et un
peu horrible je vous préviens d'avancé
ça s'appelle way that sox ya pas le clin
d'oeil souvent c'est des gens qui
postent un truc qui vient de leur
arriver est vraiment qui est horrible
qui nul de ouf
du coup ça devient une sorte de ready to
tu rigole vraiment du malheur des autres
je sais c'est horrible alors attention
on rigole non pas genre aah est bien
fait pas du tout on rigole juste parce
que moi quand je suis face à une
situation qui met ou un truc qui met
trop mal à l'aise je ris nerveusement ça
m'a fait beaucoup de tours dans ma vie
[Musique]
en vrai je pars du principe que s'ils
l'ont mis au final sur serez dit c'est
qu'ils s'en sont sortis que ça va mieux
et pas qu'ils sont dans un sos total et
que leur vie s'achève là pas du tout
pourquoi j'aime c'est qu'en fait tous
ces petits problèmes qu'on s'inflige au
quotidien la petite musique est moins
sûr tous ces problèmes qu'on s'inflige
au quotidien tout ce que tu considères
des problèmes dans ta vie c'est pas tant
des problèmes par rapport à ce que ces
gens traversent bref on commence avec si
vous traversez une mauvaise journée
souvenez-vous juste que vous pourriez
être ce gars qui conduit un bus rempli
de potentiel personnes atteintes du
coronavirus en direction d'une zone de
quarantaine le tout sous le regard
aiguisé et d'un policier en beauté il
est abattu
les événements l'ont complètement
dépassés excusez-moi atteint logement
donc c'était vraiment pas une bonne idée
de faire ce billet je vais passer pour
un monstre mais mieux vaut rire que
juste de pleurer pour lui si c'est sur
ce timbre est dit c'est que ça va mieux
depuis
[ __ ] ça se trouve il est mort à la
demande alors à ses heures perdues mon
ami est mannequin pour les photos libres
de droits aux le shooteur stocks lui
voulait tous je suis là bas voilà en
gros de la vie de cette personne fait ça
en fait je viens de le voir sur une
affiche qui sensibilise à la
prostitution acheter du sexe
soyez condamné au nom c'est tellement
drôle j'imagine que c'est un pote à moi
ça me tue enfin c'est drôle la situation
de ce gars n'a pas la fiche où la
prostitution est évidemment un
désamorçage désamorcer alors au colorado
à cause d'une chute de rochers un chemin
de 20 km est maintenant devenu un chemin
de 238 km avec quatre heures et demie de
détours quoi quitte à avoir 80 milles
devant toi appelle des potes et dégager
les rochers pas fait un truc
croyable ces détours là je relativise a
tué sur les fois où je fais un petit
détour parce qu'il ya des travaux là sur
la route tu as [ __ ] parisien jaurès a
par exemple grand père n'a pas seulement
réussi une chemise qu'il possédait déjà
non il la portait le jour où il a reçu
l'armée gros site off ce cadeau tu fais
un truc genre tu attends pas qui louche
je sais pas tu le dis tu dis grand-père
désolé ouf pas ça sert à rien tu l'as
déjà sur le dow lâche majestueux
j'aurais tellement honte qu'ils ouvrent
et qu'ils aient le même cadeau que ce
que je l'offre déjà sur lui directement
j'aurais fait mine d'avoir oublié le
cadeau c'est peut-être un peu lâche je
suis pas d'excusés sur un gros match
alors j'ai pas lu le titre j'ai la
flemme
attends je viens de comprendre pourquoi
tous les gens tout ce qui est métallique
dans la rue les gens ne marche pas tu
m'aimes quand il fait beau et qui la
zéro plus quoi les gens ne marche pas
dessus
vraiment même vous je suis sûr parmi
vous il y en a pleins ils se rendent pas
compte mais ils marchent pas sur les
grilles les plaques extra il les évite
moi je fais jamais guerre je m'en bats
les steaks vraiment mais qu'en fait
c'était moins l'idiot c'était moi
l'ignorant c'est terrifiant mec donc
juste le clown de sound soula et c'est
parfait leur avion a décollé il y a deux
heures au nom bas hantise mec
comment je suis un stressé sur ça à
chaque fois tout le monde je crois mais
d'un autre côté là j'ai envie de rire
quoi mais je vais pas lire par respect
je travaille dans un coffee shop sans
faire exprès mon boss a versé des grains
non torréfié dans un lot de grains
torréfiés voici moi et mon collègue ses
parents dix mille grains à la main il ya
un truc un peu satisfaisant quand même
non on devrait pas si grave
c'est comme faire un puzzle je sais pas
bien tout satisfaisant là tu sais par le
non jeu le sol est une femme glisse sur
la glace allons l'aider en cours en a
très peu agréable solidarité
sympa aujourd'hui j'utilise mon travail
après cinq ans de service des 500
personnes affiliées j'ai travaillé voici
ma carte de départ la faiblesse ça
m'exaspère
les chiens [ __ ] efforts quoi même si
vous embêter les couilles c'est
franchement ça vous prendre dix secondes
de marc et bonne continuation frérot
même si c'est pas ton frère ou du tout
c'est pas grave je sais que c'est pas
bien mais j'ai tellement ri en a arrêté
non j'aime pas j'aime pas série où la
minute d'après tu l'as pas sans
culpabiliser ils sont désagréables
[Musique]
bogui d'ascq soit une fin de carrière
baba si j'y vais à fond je profite
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais
c'était l'homme et mais je sais pas
s'ils vont en découdre mais là la
vitesse à laquelle elle tourne c'est
extrêmement violent physiquement pas
fait jusque là sur une chaise de bureau
comme un combat vous allez voir déjà
vous allez beaucoup moins vite que ça te
suis vraiment jean-michel logos en 2020
je dis des trucs je m'excuse howe est
cette enfant c'est manger un poteau
pendant qu'il courait après son
footballeur préféré au nom et au nom il
est d'une mignonne riz c'est horrible et
cool à la fois parce que du coup il a eu
sa photo et lui look même pas élu fait
les premiers soins avant la faute alors
fais ta photo là gamin de merde alors
qu'elle bat à et lui renvoyer la
mauvaise taille à des salaires très
drôle j'ai jamais vu une merde pareille
de toute ma vie c'est pas la taille qui
a tu peux te tromper d'une taille ou
deux mais là je crois que ça a l'air des
[Musique]
134 50 fois la taille du bail
waaa assez génial je suis là aller sur
un site spécial de fringues où ils
vendent des pantalons pour les gens qui
sont très très très très grands skippers
cool parce qu'effectivement quant à une
corpulence vraiment atypique des fois tu
galères à table ah ça va tuer c'est un
rideau monga spontanée c'est incroyable
une partie amusante de thé 30 ans quand
tu te lèves tu te dis que tu es en
gueule de bois et puis tu te souviens
que non c'est juste l'état ton corps une
fois la trentaine dépassée 2 ouf
trop d'accord j'ai l'aref à mort ça
m'arrive tout le temps mon nouveau rumba
est passé sur le caca de mon chiot et a
ensuite procédé au nettoyage du reste de
ma maison fois je te comprends mec je
sais ce que tu ressens ça m'est arrivé
une fois avec un chat et j'ai arrêté le
combat
simplement je pense que lui aussi je
pense qu'il n'a pas eu trop le choix vu
l'état du truc voilà un malchanceux
problème d'éclairage
[Musique]
aujourd'hui est un jour de chance ne le
foie repas aya un plan caméra sur lui il
montre sa bannière
ah non je suis heureux pour lui tu as le
caméraman a été cool comme vraiment à un
gros big up hobereau les caméras ils
sont très patients avec plus de 100
enfants attendait de voir passer ce
train à vapeur historique d'angleterre
wayne très heureux il va il est nul
ils marchent pas c'est quoi la chute
[Musique]
la vie est impitoyable certaines de mes
commandes sur allier express ne sont
jamais arrivés et m'ont demandé des
preuves en photo quoi comment tu veux
prouver que ces jeunes c'est chiant je
me souviendrai toujours de la fois où
j'étais à une fête ont joué à action
vérité indémodable quant à moins de 15
ans j'ai choisi action est la personne
m'a dit tu dois rentrer chez eux
c'est au rite en mai mais qui a des
humains vous avez zéro puis c'est quoi
ces eaux là zéro de chez zéro c'est une
violence mais avec ces fous et voilà mon
casque à 300 dollars [ __ ] ouais mais
cette position et ce visage tu vas faire
quoi tu vas faire aussi fait graver un
champ vide
je connais très bien je le vis avec un
[ __ ] de chiba qui dort juste là un
nouveau squelette a été trouvé à pompéi
c'est une ancienne ville romaine qui a
été enseveli par la lave
suite à l'éruption d'un volcan j'étais
d'audience bédard j'aime voulais pas me
planter il ya un nouveau escalettes qui
a été trouvé à pompéi est en fait c'est
le squelette d'un mec qui était en train
de s'enfuir à cause de l'éruption et il
sait manger une pierre de 300 kg
directement dans le visage
enfin pas rire mais [ __ ] le destin il
est dur d joie vous rejoignez dû à
chaque fois vous vous sentez pas bien
repenser à ce prisonnier brésilien qui a
creusé un tunnel pour s'échapper pendant
cinq ans mais qui donnait en fait sur la
chambre des gardiens de tous les
endroits possibles ça pouvait donner
c'est le pire c'est ouf cinq ans de
travail pour ça même les gardiens rigole
moyens c'est terrible j'étais dans un
parc et j'ai trouvé une biche abandonné
on lui a trouvé un bon foyer frérot je
suis désolé tu as porté les mauvaises
nouvelles mais les bébés biche reste
seul au même endroit en attendant le
retour de leur mère corps et pensent
avoir sauvé une biche il l'a kidnappée
wow rim
j'ai rompu avec ma copine au restaurant
elle a commencé à pleurer tout le monde
pensait que je l'avais demandé en
mariage et a donc commencé à applaudir
un c hambre ça c'est le pourquoi du des
fois en public les gens réagissent pas
parce qu'en fait les situations ils sont
pas si obvious qu'elle paraisse en fait
parfois parfois talentueux qui se passe
un truc en fait ils se passent
totalement autre chose et du coup si tu
réagis à ce truc tu passes pour un méga
débile moi je suis très stoïque en
public je jamais intervenir applaudir
crier ma chambre ce que j'ai toujours
des doutes sur ce qui se passe
réellement et là ça me confirme que j'ai
raison de faire ça parce que si j'avais
applaudi cette meuf ce jour là je m'en
serais venu à mort
très bon et bien écoutez je vous sens
mieux j'ai honte de le dire mais je me
sens mieux fait relativiser c'est une
manière comme une autre de la diviser
havre il ya un vrai truc nerveux de
façon avec ça moi je me soigne anecdotes
tout j'avais un gars dans ma classe
quand j'étais au collège il faisait
graver la gueule il n'était pas bien il
avait mal répondu à la prof et la prof
elle avait un peu engueulé lui avais dit
écoute ma grand-mère est morte hier donc
vraiment me fais pas chier et là il ya
un bon silence et il ya une meuf dans la
classe qui explose de ré et le gars de
ma classe lui a tout simplement lancé du
chef directement sur elle est en fait la
pauvre c'est pas qu'elle rayé de la
situation et qu'elle riez parce que la
grand-mère de l'otite est décédé pas du
tout c'est juste qu'elle avait le rire
nerveux et que quand une situation hyper
malaise en théorie bhl et ben il y en a
ils réagissent par le rire toi et moi
avant j'étais un peu comme ça là je me
suis un peu calmé mais c'est chaud le
rire nerveux attention faites attention
ça peut vraiment blessé des gens mais
c'est dur des fois c'est nerveux quoi
bref voilà je vous mets le lien
description comme d'hab fait un petit
tour des fois quand vous n'êtes pas bien
passé sur celui-là et vous verrez vous
sentir un peu moins seul
oui vous arrive des trucs bien bas dans
je fais des très gros bisous c'est ciao
[Musique]
tél